Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest is History. Now, as many of you will know, we have embarked on a colossal marathon taking in every single one of the 32 countries that has qualified for the FIFA World Cup in Qatar. And we are talking about aspects of those countries' histories. Now, today we alight on the shores of the great North American country of Canada. Now, you might think Canada is an odd place to have qualified for the World Cup because it doesn't
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。正如大家所知，我们已经展开了一场宏大的马拉松，涵盖了所有32个获得卡塔尔世界杯参赛资格的国家。我们要探讨的是这些国家历史的各个方面。今天，我们将把目光投向伟大的北美国家——加拿大。大家可能会觉得，加拿大获得世界杯资格是一件很奇怪的事，因为它并没有
have a terribly distinguished footballing history. But Tom, it does have an amazing sporting claim to fame, doesn't it? Because am i not right in thinking that canada took part in the world's first ever international sporting fixture of any kind it was against the united states and um the sport was amazingly cricket so not ice hockey so that's our subject for today is it the canadian cricket no i was i i was very very tempted to do the history of canadian cricket but i decided not to um and instead i i thought that i would focus on something else that is very very close to my heart a truly admirable mammal dominic yes and a mammal that in many ways is i guess the uh the stanley baldwin of of the animal world and it's the beaver and i describe it as the stanley baldwin of the animal world because it's it's kind of the in a way the embodiment of the kind
一段非常显赫的足球历史。但汤姆，它确实拥有一个令人惊叹的体育辉煌纪录，对吧？因为如果我没记错的话，加拿大参加了世界上第一场任何类型的国际体育比赛，对手是美国，而且……嗯，这项运动居然是板球，而不是冰球。所以这就是我们今天的主题，加拿大板球吗？不，我……我本来非常非常想讲加拿大板球史，但我决定不讲了；相反，我……我想专注于另一件非常非常贴近我内心的事情，一种真正令人钦佩的哺乳动物，多米尼克。是的，这种哺乳动物在许多方面可以说是动物界的斯坦利·鲍德温，它就是海狸。我之所以把它描述为动物界的斯坦利·鲍德温，是因为它在某种程度上是这种
of conservatism that stanley baldwin embodied so it's a proud homeowner so it makes you know these wonderful kind of homes yeah very monogamous uh so lifelong married relationship like stanley and what was her name? And Lucy. And Lucy. Yeah. Or later the Empress Theodora, if you listen to our episode about Love Island. You know, cares for its young, all that kind of thing. Very hardworking, obviously busy chopping down trees and all that kind of stuff. So in a way, the kind of the embodiment of a kind of conservative ideal, if you like.
保守主义的化身，正如斯坦利·鲍德温所体现的那样。它是一个骄傲的房主，会建造这种极好的住所；是的，非常一夫一妻制，有着终身伴侣关系，就像斯坦利和……她叫什么来着？还有露西。还有露西。是的。或者后来的狄奥多拉皇后，如果你听过我们关于《爱情岛》的那期节目的话。你知道的，关爱幼崽，诸如此类。非常勤劳，显然忙着砍树以及所有这些事情。所以在某种程度上，可以说是保守主义理想的化身，如果你愿意这么认为的话。
And it's kind of served as an emblem, if not for Canada, then certainly for Canadian history. So Canadians have always had a slightly ambivalent relationship to the beaver. So it has served them as a symbol of their country. So 1851, its very first postage stamp, do you know what it was called, Dominic? The beaver stamp tom it was called the threepence beaver dominic so it uh depicted a beaver crouching on a bank uh behind beside a stream um obviously cost 3p but when in 1921 canada wanted a coat of arms and there was a lot of discussion about what animal should be on it they didn't go for the beaver they go for the moose they went for the moose and the reason that that they didn't
它某种程度上成了一种象征，如果不是加拿大的象征，那也绝对是加拿大历史的象征。所以加拿大人对海狸一直有一种稍微矛盾的关系。它曾作为他们国家的象征——比如1851年，他们发行的第一枚邮票，你知道它叫什么吗，多米尼克？海狸邮票，汤姆。它被称为“三便士海狸”，多米尼克。所以它……它描绘了一只蹲在小溪边河岸上的海狸；显然售价是3便士。但当1921年加拿大想要一个国徽，并且对上面应该用什么动物进行了很多讨论时，他们没有选择海狸，而是选择了驼鹿。他们选择了驼鹿，而他们不
want the beaver was because uh the guy responsible for it said they didn't want a rat oh what which was harsh well because because the beaver is a rodent but it's not actually a rat so it was it was robbed so that's harsh isn't it it's harsh's harsh. But I mean, I think the fact that the beaver was in the running kind of illustrates how significant an animal it is. But it's not just that it's an emblem of Canada itself. As I said, it's an emblem of Canadian history. Yes. Because it goes back to the very beginnings of human habitation in what becomes Canada. And it runs right through the history of the native peoples in Canada, the coming of the Europeans, the war between the British and French, industrialization, ecological collapse, and then ecological recovery.
想要海狸的原因是……负责设计的那个人说他们不想要一只老鼠。噢！这未免太苛刻了吧。好吧，因为海狸是一种啮齿动物，但它实际上并不是老鼠，所以它被冤枉了。所以这很苛刻，不是吗？太苛刻了，太苛刻了。但我的意思是，海狸能够进入候选名单这一事实，某种程度上说明了它是一种多么重要的动物。但不仅因为它本身是加拿大的象征，正如我所说，它是加拿大历史的象征。是的。因为它追溯到了后来成为加拿大的这片土地上人类居住的最早时期，贯穿了加拿大原住民的历史、欧洲人的到来、英法战争、工业化、生态崩溃，然后是生态恢复。
Crikey. There's a lot going on there, Tom. It's a great, great window onto the vast sweep of Canadian history. Okay. Great. Let's go for it so there've been various species of beaver that have existed in canada of which the most extraordinary is castoriodes uh which is uh aka the giant beaver dominic so it was a giant beaver that's very much very much what it says on thanks for. Thanks for that, Tom. That's your capacitors, David. Top paleontological information there. So that was kind of roaming Canada about one and a half million years ago.
天哪。那里面发生的事情可真多啊，汤姆。这是一扇极好的、极好的窗户，让我们得以窥见加拿大历史的宏大扫视。好吧。太棒了，我们开始吧。加拿大曾存在过各种海狸物种，其中最非凡的是拟河狸（Castoroides），也就是俗称的巨型海狸，多米尼克。所以它是一只巨大的海狸，这完全……完全就是字面意思。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢你提供古生物学信息，大卫。那里有顶级的古生物学信息。所以它大约在一百五十万年前漫游在加拿大。
And we say giant, how big? About the size of a black bear. Ooh, that is big. So it wasn't going around chopping down trees and building dams and things. Yeah. It was more like, I think the ecological niche that it inhabited, It wasn't going around chopping down trees and building dams and things. It was more like, I think, the ecological niche that it inhabited. It's been compared to a hippo.
当我们说“巨型”时，到底有多大？大约有一头黑熊那么大。哦，那确实很大。所以它不是到处跑去砍树、筑坝之类的。是的。更像是……我认为它所占据的生态位……它不是到处跑去砍树、筑坝之类的。更像是……我认为它所占据的生态位。它被拿来和河马做比较。
So it was kind of like a little hippo. Tom, it's just a stupid question. Yeah. Because you know I know nothing about zoology, science, or the natural world. Are there not beavers in Europe? We'll come to that. Okay. All right. We will come to that. It's a cliffhanger. Europe? We'll come to that. Okay. All right. We will come to that.
所以它有点像一只小河马。汤姆，这是一个愚蠢的问题吗？是的。因为你知道我对动物学、科学或自然界一无所知。欧洲没有海狸吗？我们等一下会讲到。好吧。好的。我们等一下会讲到。这是一个悬念。欧洲？我们等一下会讲到。好吧。好的。我们等一下会讲到。
It's a cliffhanger. Yeah, we will come to that. So the giant beaver was not in Europe. So this was specific to North America and the north of North America. And it was large, very large. And it was alive and roaming the wilds of North America until about 10,000 years ago. And so the inevitable question is the question that we asked. I don't even remember we did an episode.
这是一个悬念。对，我们等一下会讲到。所以巨型海狸不在欧洲。这是北美洲以及北美北部所特有的。它很大，非常大。直到大约一万年前，它都还活着，漫游在北美洲的荒野中。因此，不可避免的问题就是我们曾问过的问题。我甚至不记得我们做过一期节目……
Of course you remember because you did it. But we did an episode on Australia before Columbus. Where there were, again, huge indigenous animals that basically went extinct around the time that humans arrived in Australia. And there is the same issue around the arrival of humans arriving across the Bering Straits, coming to North America. And it's kind of around this time that the giant beaver is going extinct. And its remains have been found with human artefacts in a cave in Ohio. And there are stories that are told by Native American peoples that seem to describe perhaps folk memories of these
你当然记得，因为那是你做的。但我们做过一期关于哥伦布到达之前的澳大利亚的节目。那里同样有巨大的本土动物，基本上在人类抵达澳大利亚时就灭绝了。而人类穿过白令海峡来到北美洲时，也存在同样的问题。差不多正是在这个时候，巨型海狸走向了灭绝。它的遗骸在俄亥俄州的一个山洞里与人类文物一起被发现。原住民讲述的故事中，似乎也描绘了对这些
giant animals. There's a brilliant book by Adrienne Meyer, who's actually a kind of classicist stroke paleontologist. And she has argued that a lot of the stories that are told by Native American peoples are derived from their coming across fossils of ancient creatures. And so one of the theories that she advances is that perhaps they don't reflect kind of enduring folk memories from 10,000 years ago, but coming across clearly the fossils of giant beavers and that this is where the stories come from. We don't know. We don't know. But anyway, the giant beaver very sadly went extinct.
巨型动物的民间记忆。阿德里安娜·迈尔（Adrienne Meyer）写过一本精彩的书，她实际上是一位古典学者兼古生物学家。她认为，原住民讲述的许多故事都源于他们偶然遇到了古代生物的化石。因此她提出的理论之一是，这些故事或许并不反映一万年前延续至今的民间记忆，而是他们偶然清晰地看到了巨型海狸的化石，故事正是由此而来。我们不知道。我们不知道。但无论如何，巨型海狸非常遗憾地灭绝了。
I mean, who wouldn't want to see a giant beaver? I'd love to see a giant beaver, Tom. Roaming the lands of the frozen Canadian North. Pin my collars to the mast on that. Yes. But that left the beaver that we're more familiar with, so this kind of smaller beaver. And North America, and particularly Canada, Dominic,
我的意思是，谁不想亲眼看看巨型海狸呢？我很想看一只巨型海狸，汤姆。漫游在严寒的加拿大北部土地上。我把我的旗帜插在这个观点上了。是的。但这留下了我们更熟悉的、这种较小的海狸。而北美洲，特别是加拿大，多米尼克，
it was full of beaver. There was so much beaver. There was so much beaver. There were so many beavers. And it's been estimated that maybe 60 million, maybe 100 million, maybe 300 million, maybe 400 million. So that is a lot of beavers. Yes. That's Adam.
到处都是海狸。有那么多的海狸。有那么多的海狸。有那么多的海狸。据估计，可能有6000万、1亿、3亿，甚至4亿只。所以那是相当多的海狸。是的。那是亚当……
Yeah. Why so many? Because they didn't have, there wasn't a predator. There wasn't a predator going for them. And they basically in terms of kind of river in riverine environments they were the apex mammal okay and and because they you know they chop down trees with their big teeth and they build dams and all that kind of stuff yeah they completely sculpt the landscapes so they reroute rivers um you know they can flood valleys basically they create in
是的。为什么会有这么多？因为它们没有……没有天敌。没有捕食它们的猎食者。就河流环境而言，它们基本上是顶级的哺乳动物。好吧，因为它们用大牙齿砍树，筑造水坝等等，是的，它们完全重塑了地貌。它们改变河流的流向，嗯，它们基本上可以淹没山谷，它们创造了
entire ecosystems that other animals other plants then depend on and so in in a sense if you had been roaming canada me personally 500 years ago yeah the landscape would look completely different because of the impact on it of beavers yeah okay interesting this is that there are lots of beavers and so therefore they are very useful to the native peoples who who come in and who settle across canada yeah because it's not like there aren't people there in this period yeah obviously they're not on the scale of of populations that will come from europe but and these are peoples who who need say fur you know it's very cold in canada that's the one thing everyone knows about canada yes it's winters are very very cold uh and these the the beaver furs are tremendously um you know that they provide you excellent, excellent insulation. So there's no question that native peoples are hunting beaver for fur.
整个生态系统，其他动物和其他植物随后都要依赖这些生态系统。所以从某种意义上说，如果你500年前在加拿大游荡，我个人，是的，由于海狸对其的影响，地貌将看起来完全不同。是的，好吧，有趣的是，有那么多的海狸，因此它们对来到加拿大并定居下来的原住民非常有用，是的，因为在这个时期并不是没有人烟，当然，它们的规模没有后来从欧洲来的人口那么多，但这些是需要……比方说皮毛的人。你知道的，加拿大非常冷，这是每个人都知道关于加拿大的唯一一件事，是的，它的冬天非常非常冷，而这些海狸皮毛极其……你知道的，它们能提供极好、极好的保暖。所以毫无疑问，原住民为了皮毛在猎捕海狸。
They're also hunting them for meat. It's very calorific. In fact, much more calorific than most other game that they could have hunted. They use the sinew for cord. They use the jawbones for snowshoes, intriguingly. They seem to have used the claws for necklaces. And Dominic, you asked me, were there beaver in Europe? Slightly different species, but basically the same. And it's interesting, Anglo-Saxon women seem to have been obsessed with beaver necklaces. So the teeth, and they would cap them with gold and they've been found in about, do they, about 20 graves. So that's a kind of interesting parallel between Anglo-Saxon England and prehistoric Canada.
他们也为了肉类而猎捕它们。这非常有营养。事实上，比他们能猎取的大多数其他野味都要有营养得多。他们用肌腱做绳索。有趣的是，他们用颌骨做雪鞋。他们似乎还用爪子做项链。多米尼克，你问过我欧洲有没有海狸？物种略有不同，但基本上是一样的。有趣的是，盎格鲁-撒克逊妇女似乎对海狸项链着迷。所以还有牙齿，她们会用黄金给它们镶嵌帽顶，在大概20座坟墓里都发现了这种东西。所以这可以说是盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰和史前加拿大之间一个有趣的平行现象。
And there is absolute, you know, we have absolute archaeological evidence. We have, you know, bones of beavers bearing the marks of knives. There was a burial found near Lake Huron, which had a copper axe with fragments of beaver pelt wrapped around it. So that was about 2,500 years ago. So beavers are very, very important to the subsistence of the native peoples.
而且我们有绝对的……你知道的，我们有绝对的考古证据。我们有……带有刀痕的海狸骨头。在休伦湖附近发现了一个墓葬，里面有一把铜斧，上面缠绕着海狸皮毛的碎片。那大约是2500年前的事了。所以海狸对于原住民的生计来说非常非常重要。
So they're hunting them, but they're not hunting them at all to the point of extermination humans and these millions and millions of beavers are are coexisting well because the human numbers are so small i mean presumably by comparison with today and then of course europeans arrive yes the late 1400s um you're starting to get fishermen going to Newfoundland from France, from Portugal, from Spain, and perhaps particularly from England. So they're hunting cod, they're hunting whales, and they start to land. And when they land, they come into contact with native peoples and they start to exchange stuff, knives, whatever. And what the native peoples can provide in exchange is beaver pelts.
所以他们在猎捕海狸，但绝对没有猎捕到灭绝的程度。人类和这数以百万计的海狸共存得很好，因为人类的数量相比之下非常少，我想大概是这样。然后，当然，欧洲人在14世纪末抵达，嗯，你开始看到渔民从法国、葡萄牙、西班牙，或许特别是从英格兰前往纽芬兰。所以他们在捕捞鳕鱼，在捕鲸，然后他们开始登陆。当他们登陆时，他们与原住民接触，开始交换物品，比如小刀之类的。而原住民能提供的回报则是海狸皮。
So to begin with, this trade in beaver fur is a sideline. Yeah. But then the traders start going inland. So rather than just kind of fishing the waters off the canadian coast they start to to sail up the rivers and the first person to leave a record of of what he finds when he starts sailing up the rivers is a french explorer called jacques cartier um and he sells up the saint lawrence river and saint lawrence river will become the kind of the great center of french culture in north america yes the great, the great artery of Quebec, basically.
所以一开始，这种海狸皮毛贸易只是一个副业。是的。但随后商人开始深入内陆。因此，他们不再仅仅在加拿大海岸附近的水域捕鱼，而是开始顺流而上。第一个留下他乘船逆流而上所见所闻记录的人，是一位名叫雅克·卡蒂埃（Jacques Cartier）的法国探险家。嗯，他沿着圣劳伦斯河航行，而圣劳伦斯河后来成为了法国文化在北美的伟大中心，是的，基本上是魁北克的伟大动脉。
And so in 1535, he describes visiting a place that will become the site of Montreal in due course. And he's told by the peoples who live there, the Iroquois, that this is a place called Hocelaga, which means in their language, the place of the beaver dam. And so that's, I gather, still a region of Montreal to this day. Okay. So it's a trace element of the uh lining the the the the various tributaries that run off the the saint lawrence river more and more fur trappers start to sail
因此在1535年，他描述了访问一个后来将成为蒙特利尔基地的地点的经历。住在在那里的易洛魁人告诉他，这个地方叫霍谢拉加（Hocelaga），在他们的语言中意思是“海狸水坝的地方”。我了解到，直到今天，那依然是蒙特利尔的一个地区。好吧。所以这是沿着……圣劳伦斯河的各种支流排列的一个痕迹元素。越来越多的毛皮捕猎者开始顺流而上，并在那里定居，以捕捉各种海狸，而原住民也开始被卷入其中。因此他们被卷入了圣劳伦斯河的巨大旋涡中，向南延伸到后来成为美国的地区以及漫长的加拿大，所以他们也都开始为此争夺。到了17世纪，你便迎来了所谓的“海狸战争”。
up it and to settle it and to uh capture the uh the various beavers and the native people start getting sucked into it so they get sucked into the uh get sucked into the great vortex of the be lawrence river and you know southwards into what will become the united states and long canada so they they all start fighting over it as well and by the 17th century you you were getting what are known as the beaver wars beaver wars and essentially what is happening is that the iroquois you know this great tribal grouping that cartier had dealings with to begin with, they're carving out, they're trying to carve out essentially the equivalent of an enormous kingdom and monopolize the fur trade with the Europeans. And this seems to have been an almost literally genocidal campaign. So they are aiming to literally destroy as many of the kind of rival tribes as
海狸战争。从本质上讲，发生的事情是，易洛魁人——卡蒂埃最初与之打交道的这个伟大部族集团——正在开辟……他们试图开辟出一个大致相当于庞大王国的领土，并垄断与欧洲人的毛皮贸易。这似乎是一场几乎字面意义上的灭绝种族运动。因此，他们的目标是字面意义上尽可能多地消灭敌对部落。所以这就是……《最后的莫希干人》，那部著名的小说。易洛魁人消灭了莫希干人。我的意思是，这就是为什么……
they possibly can. So this is, you know, the last of the Mohicans, the famous novel. The Iroquois wipe out the Mohicans. I mean, that's why there's,
所以这就是为什么他是最后一个莫希干人。是的。而他们……他们的主要目标是休伦人，休伦湖显然就是以他们命名的，我们刚才已经提到了。还有阿尔冈昆人，就像那个著名的俱乐部一样。是的。所以阿尔冈昆人和休伦人与法国人进行贸易。
so that's why he's the last of the Mohicans. Yes. And they, their main targets are the Hurons who obviously give their name to late Huron. We've already mentioned that. And the Algonquins, as in the famous club. Yes. So the Algonquins and Hurons are trading with the French.
因此法国人支持他们。不可避免地，易洛魁人因此得到了英国人和荷兰人的支持。所以这是一场可怕的殖民与美洲原住民仇恨和敌对的乱局。到了17世纪末，这对原住民部落的影响是如此具有毁灭性，欧洲贸易商的涌入又是如此巨大，以至于欧洲人开始能够甩开美洲原住民中间商，亲自夺取对贸易的控制权。法国人有一种模式，他们资助一种独立的商人，被称为“森林越轨者”（coureurs du bois）。基本上就是森林奔跑者。
So the French back them. And the Iroquois inevitably, therefore, are backed by the English and the Dutch. And so it's a kind of horrific snarl of colonial and Native American hatreds and rivalries. And by the end of the 17th century, the effect of this on the Native tribes is so devastating. And the influx of European traders is so large that Europeans are starting to be able to cut out the Native American middlemen and seize control of the trade themselves. The French have a model where they sponsor kind of independent traders, coureurs du bois, they're called. So woodrunners, basically.
是的，基本上是这样。这反映了这样一个事实：他们才是真正深入加拿大腹地、探索它、绘制地图等等的人。因为海狸正从更容易接近的地点开始消失。所以它们在那里消失得越多，你为了寻找它们就得走得越远。西班牙人也在这样做。所以对于法国人来说，海狸……同样如此。
Yeah, basically. And it reflects the fact that they are the ones who are going very, very deep into the hearts of the vitals of Canada and kind of exploring it, mapping it, all that kind of thing. Because the beavers are starting to vanish from the more readily accessible locations. So the more they vanish from there, the further you have to go and search for them. The Spanish are doing the same as well. So for the French, the beaver same as well um so for for the french the beaver is le castor and for the spanish is il castor and so that's why you get a lot of places in in north america that kind of bear witness to this so you have castorville bayou castor
所以对于法国人来说，海狸是“le castor”，对于西班牙人来说是“el castor”。这就是为什么在北美有许多地方见证了这一点：你有卡斯托维尔（Castorville）、卡斯托河湾（Bayou Castor）、海狸湖（Lac du Castor）、索利泰尔、卡斯托草原（Prairie du Castor）、海狸角（Castor Point）、卡斯托岬（Castor Plunge）以及许多其他类似的地名，还有许多类似海狸溪之类的名字。是的，遍布加拿大各地，绝对是这样，因为当然英国人也参与进来了。1670年，（当然也有英国的独立猎人），他们走向了……他们在1670年从查理二世那里成立了一家大公司，获得了一份特许状，官方名称为“英格兰杰出商人探索哈德逊湾总督与公司”，也就是人们更熟知的哈德逊湾公司。而哈德逊湾特许状的作用是，它赋予获得特许状的人对大片广袤领土的独家权利。这基本上就是哈德逊湾周围所有的土地，哈德逊湾位于加拿大北部，是一个巨大的水域。所有汇入其中的河流，所有这些都交给了英国商人。这个地区被称为“鲁珀特地”（Rupert's Land），得名于节目的老朋友鲁珀特王子。哦，天哪。查理二世的叔子。鲁珀特王子竟然在一档以海狸为主题的播客中登场了。
lac du castor solitaire prairie du castor castor point castor plunge lots of others like that and lots of kind of beaver creeks and stuff like that yes across canada absolutely because of course the english are also getting involved and in 1670 that you know there are individual trappers of course that who are english too but they go for the kind of they they set up a large company in 1670 from charles ii they get a charter for what is officially called the Governor and Company of Adventurers of England trading into Hudson's Bay, which is better known as the Hudson's Bay Company. And what the Hudson's Bay Charter does is that it gives those who've been given the
是的，他绝对登场了。我的意思是，所以大约是……我的意思是，这几乎是加拿大的一半。大约占现代加拿大的40%。所以这是一大片领土。我的加拿大地理不太好。所以我刚刚用谷歌搜索了加拿大的一张地图……所以这是一大片领土。我正看着……我的加拿大地理不太好，所以我刚刚用谷歌搜索了加拿大地图。我的意思是，汤姆，哈德逊湾几乎有西欧那么大。我的意思是，极其巨大。
charter exclusive rights to a vast, vast swathe of territory. So it's basically all the lands about Hudson's Bay, which is in the north of Canada. It's a huge expanse of water. And all the rivers that are kind of draining into it, all of this is given over to English traders. And it's a region that is called Rupert's Land after friend of the show, Prince Rupert. Oh, crikey. Charles II's uncle. Prince Rupert's a pitch up in a beaver themed podcast.
这是一片极其广袤的开阔地。而且基本上是免费的。所以他们为这份特许状所要付出的全部代价是，如果国王或他的任何继承人或继任者进入鲁珀特地，那么公司必须交出两只黑海狸和两只雄鹿。但显然，你知道，查理二世或……的可能性微乎其微。绝对微乎其微。事实上，这件事第一次付诸实施是在未来的爱德华八世——当时他是威尔士亲王——
Yes, he absolutely has. I mean, so it's about, I mean, it's almost half of Canada. It's about 40% of modern day Canada. So it's a huge amount of territory. My Canadian geography is not brilliant. So I just Googled a mapday Canada. So it's a huge amount of territory. I'm just looking at – my Canadian geography is not brilliant, so I just Googled a map of Canada. I mean, Hudson Bay, Tom, is pretty much the size of Western Europe. I mean, gigantic.
在1927年，他去加拿大进行了一次旅行，他在温尼伯停留，或者在前往阿尔伯塔省的途中，他在那里有一个养牛场。所以他们不得不交出一对黑海狸和一对雄鹿。雄鹿……我确信爱德华八世会喜欢这个的。是的，但你可能还记得，我们做过……一期关于伦敦塔动物园里动物的节目，嗯，哈德逊湾公司送了一只熊，一只非常暴躁的熊，我记得，给……乔治三世，而他很失望，因为他一直希望得到一件皮草大衣。这就引发了一个我想问的问题，关于海狸的用途。嗯，我们会讲到的，多米尼克。
It's an enormous, enormous expanse. And basically it's free. So all they have to do in return for this charter is that should the king or any of his heirs or successors enter Rupert's land, then the company has to hand over two black beavers and two elk. But obviously, you know, the likelihood that Charles II or... Slimo. Absolutely slim. And in fact, the first time that this kicked in was when the future Edward VIII, so he was Prince of Wales,
好吧。哦，我是不是跳跃得太快了？不，我们稍后会讲到，但我只是想说，显然这片土地并不真的是查理二世的，不能由他送人，它已经属于原住民了，他们已经在那里了。而且，为什么法国人要承认一个英国国王在送出所有这些土地呢？特许状的颁发、哈德逊湾公司的成立并没有结束法国和英国毛皮猎人之间的冲突，恰恰相反。在18世纪的进程中，它极大地加剧了英国和法国之间的殖民竞争。在七年战争期间，海狸绝对处于……国际层面的核心。所以除了印度之外，加拿大也是七年战争中争夺的大片领土之一。这就是那场见证了加拿大历史上最著名战役的战争，当时沃尔夫将军攻占了魁北克。
in 1927, he went on a tour of Canada and he stopped in Winnipeg or en route to Alberta where he had a cattle ranch. And so they had to hand over two black beavers and a pair of elk elk i'm sure every eighth would love that yeah but also you may remember in we did um an episode on uh animals in the tower of london yeah menagerie and they and they the hudson's bay company gave a bear a very grumpy bear i do um to uh george the third which and he was disappointed
哦，那是一场伟大的战役，是英国历史上最伟大的战役之一，更不用说加拿大历史了。我的意思是，这是一个非常戏剧性的故事。是的，它灵感启发了本杰明·韦斯特（Benjamin West）的名画。是的，纳尔逊曾对此赞赏有加。纳尔逊曾说：“你为什么不画这样的画呢？”是的。因此，结果是，不仅对加拿大，而且对加拿大海狸皮毛贸易，现在都有了统一的控制。英国垄断了海狸。
because he'd been hoping for a fur code well that raises a question i wanted to ask about the uses of the beaver well we'll come to that dominic okay oh am i jumping ahead no we will come to that but i just wanted to say that obviously this land is not really charles seconds to give it already belongs to native peoples, already there. But also, why should the French acknowledge an English king giving away all this land? The issuing of the charter, the Hudson's Bay Company, does not end the conflict between French and English trappers, quite the opposite. And over the course of the 18th century, it massively fuels colonial rivalries between England and France. And during the Seven Years' War, Canada is absolutely at the heart of the
说到这里，汤姆，我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，你可以给我们讲讲海狸的现代故事。如果你喜欢海狸，这绝对是适合你的播客。一会儿见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和提早获取现场门票，请前往 therestsentertainment.com。那是 therestsentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。现在，在我们开始今天节目的下半部分之前，我只是想宣读一封来自加拿大阿里（Ari）的电子邮件。
kind of international dimension of it. So with India, Canada is one of the great territories that is up for grabs in the Seven Years' War. This is the war that sees probably the most famous battle in Canadian history when General Wolfe captures Quebec. Oh, that's a great, one of the greatest battles in British history, let alone Canadian history. I mean, it's such a dramatic story. Yes, and it inspires the famous painting by Benjamin West. Yes, that Nelson admired. And Nelson said, why don't you paint pictures like that? Yeah. And so as a result of that, there is now unitary control, not just of Canada, but therefore of the trade in beaver furs in Canada. Britain monopolizes the beaver.
亲爱的汤姆和多米尼克，我是一个来自加拿大的11岁小孩，我和妈妈一起听你们的播客。阿里说，你们的播客非常棒，除了在你们关于美国和英格兰的节目中几乎从不提加拿大。在那期节目中，你们谈到了1812年战争，却只提了一次加拿大。你们为什么不多提提加拿大呢？谢谢你们的时间，阿里。好吧，阿里，我希望今天的节目没有辜负你的期望。如果辜负了，当然，你知道该怪谁。那个罪魁祸首就是汤姆·霍兰德。所以，汤姆，我们正在谈论海狸。我们已经来到了《巴黎条约》，我认为这可以说是加拿大海狸历史上的一个里程碑。英国现在控制了这笔利润极其丰厚的贸易。那么，接下来你要带我们去哪儿？
On that note, Tom, we should take a quick break. And when we come back, you can tell us about the modern story of the beaver. And if you like beavers, this is definitely the podcast for you. See you in a minute. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hy hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestersentertainment.com. That's therestersentertainment.com. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, before we start the second half of today's
嗯，当你占领了一个充满小溪、森林、山脉和草原的广袤新世界时，你会想知道你得到了什么。因此，紧随七年战争之后的几十年里——这场战争当然也伴随着美国独立战争，当时后来成为美国的英国殖民地不再属于英国，因此加拿大对英国王室而言变得愈发重要——人们想知道外面有什么。所以在18世纪末、19世纪初，你看到了对加拿大进行系统测绘的尝试。与之相关的大名是一个名叫大卫·汤普森（David Thompson）的人，他走出去，绘制了加拿大的地图，起初是为哈德逊湾公司绘制，后来是为一家竞争对手公司绘制，这家公司同样对经营海狸皮毛非常感兴趣。汤普森被描述为加拿大历史上伟大的制图师、伟大的地理学家。
episode, I just wanted to read out an email from Ari in Canada. Dear Tom and Dominic, I'm an 11-year-old kid from Canada and my mom and I listen to your podcast. Your podcast, says Ari, is very good, except you barely ever mention Canada in your episode about the USA and England. In that episode, you talked about the War of 1812 and you mentioned Canada once. Why don't you mention Canada more? Thank you for your time, Ari. Well, Ari, I hope that today's episode has lived up to your expectations. And if it hasn't, of course, you know who to blame. And that person is Tom Holland. So Tom, we are talking beaver. We have reached the Treaty of Paris, which I think is something
1814年，他出版了这张令人难以置信的地图，它是如此精确，以至于一个世纪后，加拿大政府仍在使用它作为他们出版地图的基础。因为他亲自去过那里，看到了加拿大地貌的广袤、规模和宏伟，看到了生活在那里的动物。所以他某种程度上走在了穿越而来的定居者前面。他写下了欧洲人到来之前的加拿大：“这个大陆，从北纬40度到北极圈，从大西洋到太平洋，可以说一直被两个截然不同的生物种群所拥有：人类，即原住民，以及海狸。”他说，所有的低地都归海狸所有，高地的所有凹地也归海狸所有。
of a landmark in the history of the Canadian beaver. And Britain is now in control of this enormously lucrative trade. So where are you taking us next? Well, when you take possession of a kind of vast new world full of creeks and forests and mountains and prairie, you want to know what you've got. And so the decades that follow the Seven Years' War, which, of course, also sees the American War of Independence, when the English colonies in what becomes the United States cease to be British. And so Canada, therefore, becomes ever more important to the British crown. People want to know what's out there. And so end of the 18th century, beginning of the 19th century, you see a systematic attempt to map Canada. And the great name associated with this is a guy called David Thompson, who goes out and he maps Canada basically first for the Hudson's Bay Company, then for a rival company, also very much interested in dealing with beaver pelts. And Thompson has been described as the great mapper, the great geographer
他亲眼目睹了长达一英里、长达一英里、长达一英里的水坝，这仍然是去野外的人可以看到的东西，人们依然会被海狸能够创造的规模所震撼。水坝，所有这些东西。而且海狸身上依然有那么多的皮毛可以剥取，以至于汤普森说，它们在整个加拿大的广阔大地上充当了人们的货币。
in Canadian history. In 1814, he publishes this incredible map that's so accurate that even a century later, the Canadian government are using it as the basis for the maps that they're publishing. Because he's been out there and seen the vastness and the scale and the basis for the maps that they're publishing. And because he's been out there and seen the vastness and the scale and the majesty of the Canadian landscape, and he's seen the animals that inhabit it. So he's kind of getting there in advance of the settlers who are moving across. And he writes about Canada in the age before Europeans arrived, that this continent from the latitude of 40 degrees north to the Arctic Circle and from the Atlantic to the Pacific Ocean may be said to have been in possession of two distinct races of beings, man, so the
你知道，那是整个加拿大经济的基础。是的。但他已经意识到，这正受到威胁，所有这一切都有可能消失。所以在1797年，他遇到了一位老克里族（Cree）老人，这位克里族老人说：“我们现在杀死海狸不费吹灰之力，我们现在富有了，富有了。”所以这很好。每个人都能从中获得巨大利润。每个人都赚得盆满钵满。但我们很快就会变穷，因为当海狸被消灭时，我们将无可依赖去购买我们家人需要的东西。陌生人现在带着铁制陷阱横扫我们的国家，我们……
native peoples, and the beaver. And he says that all the lowlands were in possession of the beaver and all the hollows of the higher grounds. And he witnessed for himself dams that were a mile long a mile long a mile long and this is still something that can be seen by people going out into into the wilds people are still capable of being stupefied by the scale of what beavers are capable of creating. The dams, all that kind of stuff. And there's still so many pelts capable of being skinned from a beaver that Thompson says that they serve people across the expanse of Canada and basically as the currency.
而且他们很快就会变穷。这是一个非常非常准确的预言，因为对海狸皮毛的需求，不仅仅是皮毛本身可以做大衣之类的东西。而是因为海狸皮毛能做出世界上最好的帽子。这种皮毛有一种特殊的品质。它们上面有倒钩，所以会互相咬合。皮毛上的这些倒钩使其
You know, that's the basis of the entire entire economy across canada yeah but he's already aware that that this is under threat and that there's a possibility that you know all of this will vanish so in 1797 he meets um an old cree man and the cree man says that we are now killing the beaver without any labor we are now rich rich. So that's great. Everyone can make a huge profit from it. Everyone's quids in. But we shall soon be poor for when the beaver are destroyed, we have nothing to depend on to purchase what we want for our families. Strangers now overrun our country with the iron traps and we,
非常适合制作毛毡，一旦你把毛毡做成某种帽子，绝对防水，所以你可以在雨中戴着这顶帽子出门，它不会直接垮掉。我们在我们的致命时尚节目中和爱丽丝·马修斯·戴维（Alice Matthews-David）探讨过这一点。是的，所以基本上所有的……如果你想象一下18世纪的一顶帽子，它可以是高顶礼帽、三角帽、双角帽、夏可帽（shako）或任何这些东西，它都是用海狸皮毛制作的。哦，所以我完全误解了。
and they will soon be poor. And this is a very, very accurate prophecy because the demand for beaver pelts, it's not just the furs in themselves provide coats or whatever. It's because beaver pelts make for the best hats in the world. There's a particular quality to the fur. They have barbs on them, and so they interlock. And these barbs on the fur make it
所以我有点想象……当你说是海狸皮毛帽子时，我有点……所以这不像戴维·克罗克特（Davy Crockett）那种？对，俄罗斯星形帽子之类的。你基本上是说，即使我戴着一顶……比方说三角帽，我在之前的播客中谈到的我那顶乡绅的帽子，当我扮演一个脑满肠肥、腐败的乡绅时，是的，那里面也会有海狸成分。因为如果它不是用海狸毛制作的，如果它不是……你知道的，如果毛毡不是用海狸毛制作的，如果你冒雨出门去驱逐你的佃农或干别的什么。是的，我会的。你当然会。
ideally suited to felting and then when you've made the felt into kind of hats absolutely waterproof so you can go out in this hat in the rain and it won't just kind of collapse and we talked about this with um with alice and matthews david in our episode on on lethal fashion yes and so basically all you know if you imagine a hat in the 18th century, so it could be a top hat or a tricorn hat or a bicorn hat or a shako or any of those things, it will have been made from a beaver pelt. Oh, so I've completely misread this.
是的。那它就会直接解体，在你脸上融化成一团毛茸茸的泥浆，这会损害你的尊严。你绝不会希望那样，对吧？确实如此。这会毁了……哦，是的。如果我在寒冷中把穷人赶出去，我在做这件事时希望戴一顶有尊严的帽子。绝对的。
So I'd kind of imagine when you said beaver pelt hats, I'd sort of... So it's not like Davy Crockett? Right,ussian star hats or something you're basically saying even if i'm wearing you know a tricorn hat my squire's hat that we talked about in a previous podcast when i'm a fat and corrupt squire yes that would have beaver in it because if it's not made from beaver fur if it's not made you know if the felt is not made from beaver fur, if you go out in the rain to evict your peasants or whatever. Yeah, which I would. Of course you would.
我在做这件事时希望戴一顶生态上有尊严的帽子。我会戴一顶生态极不友好的帽子，没错。所以不仅……多米尼克，不仅你可以驱逐佃农，你还可以获得这样的安慰：你知道自己同时也在消灭北美大陆上最奇妙的生物之一。这就是我一直以来所追求的，汤姆。你这是一石二鸟啊。是的，一石二海狸。所以关键在于，它在湿润的天气里能保持坚挺——这就是关键。好吧。那是海狸最棒的地方。这就是我在帽子里寻找的特质。
Yes. Then it would just disintegrate and kind of melt into a furry sludge down your face, which would inhibit your dignity. You wouldn't want that at all, would you? It would indeed. It would ruin. Oh, yeah. If I'm throwing poor people out in the cold, I want to have a dignified hat while I'm doing it. Absolutely.
一石二海狸。所以关键在于，它在湿润的天气里能保持坚挺——这就是关键。那就是海狸最棒的地方。这就是我在帽子里寻找的特质。它保持坚挺。那是美妙绝伦的事情。对。因此，有巨大、巨大的财富可以去赚取。而这些财富不仅仅是欧洲的财富。纽约大亨的原型、开创者是约翰·雅各布·阿斯特（John Jacob Astor）。哦，是的，当然。他最初是德国人，来到英国，然后去了美洲，去了纽约。
I want to have an eco dignified hat while i'm doing it i would have an eco unfriendly hat exactly so not only not at dominic not only can you evict peasants but you can have the consolation of knowing that you're also destroying one of the most remarkable creatures in the north american continent this is the kind of stuff i'm all about some you're killing two birds with one stone yeah two beavers with one stone so the thing is it stays stiff in wet weather that's that's the key okay that's the great thing about beaver that's what i look for in a hat stays Two beavers with one stone. So the thing is, it stays stiff in wet weather. That's the key. That's the great thing about beaver.
他通过经营海狸皮毛贸易发了财。他把海狸皮毛从加拿大进口到曼哈顿，然后出口到欧洲。接着他多元化投资于鸦片贸易和曼哈顿房地产，以及所有这些在纽约赚钱的万无一失的方法。到他去世时，这种海狸皮毛贸易使他成为了美国最富有的人。他的净资产达到2000万美元，据计算，这相当于今天杰夫·贝索斯的财富。所以这大约占他一生中美国整个GDP的1%。而且他一直非常非常清楚自己的财富归功于什么。所以他有一艘船就叫“海狸号”。
That's what I look for in a hat. It stays stiff. That's the wonderful thing. Right. And so there are huge, huge fortunes to be made. And these fortunes are not just European fortunes. The original, the archetype, the trendsetter of the New York plutocrat is John Jacob Astor. Oh, yes, of course. So originally he's German, he's come to England, and then he goes to America, to New York.
如果你今天去曼哈顿的阿斯特广场（Astor Place），你仍然会到处看到海狸的标志。天哪。所以某种程度上是为了纪念……汤姆，我正在这个播客里学习知识。这才是这一切的意义所在，不是吗？是的，它……嗯，确实是。是的。
And he makes his fortune trading in beaver pelts. He imports them from Canada to Manhattan, and then he exports them to Europe. And then he diversifies into opium dealing and Manhattan real estate and all these fail-proof ways for making money in New York. And by the time of his death, this beaver pelt trading has made him the richest man in the US. So he's worth $20 million, which it's been calculated as equivalent to the wealth of Jeff Bezos today. So it's about 1% of the entire GDP of the United States in his lifetime. And he is always very, very aware of what he owes his fortune to. So he has a ship called the Beaver.
你看，你刚才还担心。你不喜欢动物学、大自然或任何诸如此类的东西。我没有担心。我很着迷。我很着迷于你想通过这个海狸生意走向何方。但事实证明，它比我以往想象的要丰富多彩得多，也深奥得多。这就是海狸的魅力所在。是的。所以，多跟我讲讲海狸吧，汤姆。
And if you go to Astor Place in Manhattan today, you'll still see Beaver emblems all over it. Crikey. So kind of memorial to... Tom, I am learning stuff in this podcast. That's what this is all about, isn't it? Yeah, it's... Well, it is. Yeah.
好的。因此，在18世纪到19世纪期间，捕猎的步伐不断加剧、加剧、再加剧。铁质陷阱是在17世纪引入的。所以这有助于助长那个世纪的海狸战争。但随后在18世纪发生的是一种捕猎海狸的技术，对海狸来说非常非常独特。好吧。因为它反映了一些一直追溯到欧洲古典古代就让人们着迷的事情
You see, you were worried. You don't like zoology or nature or any of that kind of stuff. I wasn't worried. I was intrigued. I was intrigued to see where you were going with this beaver business. But it's turned out to be much more colourful and much richer than I had ever imagined. That's beaver for you. Yeah. So talk to me more about beavers, Tom.
关于海狸的事……它们的牙齿？不，不是。是一种叫做“海狸香”（castoreum）的物质，这是一种它们分泌的黄色黏液。所以……当它们挖掘……你知道的，它们建造水坝或房子之类的东西，是的，它们会分泌这种黄色黏液，然后它们会在黄色黏液上小便，从而创造出一种……在黄色黏液上小便，创造出一种混合糊状物，用来标记它们的领地。真的吗？是的。所以人们不确定这种海狸香是从哪里来的。古希腊人认为它来自它们的睾丸。它其实不是来自睾丸，据我了解，生物学称之为特殊的囊。当你上次说你想做一期关于海狸的播客时，汤姆，我不得不承认，我曾担心它会涉及特殊的囊。事实证明确实如此。
Okay. So over the 18th century into the 19th century, the pace of trapping just intensifies, intensifies, and intensifies. And iron traps have been introduced in the 17th century. So that helped to fuel the beaver wars of that century. But then what happens in the 18th century is a technique for trapping beaver that is very, very distinctive to the beavers. Okay. Because it reflects something that right the way back to classical antiquity in Europe had always kind of fascinated
事实证明确实如此。所以希腊人认为这些是睾丸。他们有一整套奇怪的理论，说什么如果海狸受到威胁，它们会把睾丸咬掉。甚至还有说法称，如果它们已经那样做了，并且第二次被猎杀，它们会向猎人露出屁股，以证明它们没有睾丸，它们已经把它们切除掉了。这反映了在古典世界以及后来的时期里，海狸香受到多么高度的珍视。罗马人把它当成一种阿司匹林。你知道的，如果你头痛或什么的……哦，天哪。你会服用一剂海狸香。
people about the beavers so their teeth no it's not it's a substance called castoreum which is a kind of yellow gunge that they secrete so so when they they dig at you know they they build a dam or whatever or a house yeah they will excrete this yellow gunge and then they will urinate over the yellow gunge to create a kind urinate over the yellow gunge to create a kind of mixture paste that will that serves to mark their territory really yeah so this castoreum people weren't sure where it came from so the greeks thought it came from their testicles it's not from testicles that it's actually from i gather what biology is called specialist sacks when you said you wanted to do a podcast on beaver tom, I have to admit, I feared that it would involve specialist sacks. And so it has proved.
什么？它也被堕胎医生使用；人们认为它可以诱发流产。但它也被用作香水的基础成分。从现代早期一直到现代时期，如果经过提炼，海狸香的香味据说是极其美妙的。而且多米尼克，同样一直延续到今天，它一直被用作冰淇淋中的香草替代品。我的天哪，汤姆，这简直是难以置信的多用途。我的意思是，如果你头痛，你……
So it has proved. And so the Greeks thought that these were testicles. And they had this whole weird thing about how if beavers were menaced, they would gnaw the testicles off. And it was even said that if they'd done that, and they were being hunted a second time, they would kind of bare their arses at the hunter to show that they didn't have testicles, that they'd already removed them. This is reflection of the degree to which in the classical world, and indeed later, castoreum was very, very prized. So the Romans used it as a kind of aspirin. It was, you know, if you had a headache or anything. Oh, for God's sake. You take a dose of castoreum.
事实确实如此。古希腊人认为这些是睾丸。他们有一种奇怪的说法，认为如果河狸受到威胁，就会把自己的睾丸咬掉。甚至还有人说，如果它们已经咬掉了睾丸，再次遭到猎杀时，它们会向猎人亮出屁股，以证明自己没有睾丸，已经切除了。这反映出在古典时期甚至更晚，海狸香受到的重视程度极高。因此，罗马人把它当作一种阿司匹林来使用。你知道的，如果你头痛或者有什么不适的话。哦，天哪。你就服用一剂海狸香。
What? It was also used by abortionists. so it was believed to induce abortion. But it was also used as the basis of perfumes. And it was throughout early modern into the modern period. Castoreum, if it's refined, apparently the scent is absolutely delicious. And Dominic, again, right the way into the present day, it has been used as a vanilla substitute in ice cream. I mean, for goodness sake, Tom is this is implausibly multi-purpose i mean what if yes you have a headache you're
什么？堕胎药也使用它，人们认为它能诱发流产。但它也被用作香水的基础成分。在从近代早期到现代的整个时期都是如此。海狸香如果经过提炼，据说香味非常美妙。多米尼克，而且直到今天，它一直被用作冰淇淋中的香草替代品。我的天哪，汤姆，这东西的用途多得难以置信，我是说，如果你头痛的话...
pregnant and you want an ice cream yeah you want an ice cream and you're going out for dinner and you want to smell good yes exactly so beavers are you know kind of very nutritious right they have fur that will enable you to wear a tricorn hat. Yeah. And they have this kind of excretion. This sort of magic stub. It's the basis for furniture and ice cream flavouring. So in every way, you can see why people are after them. But the kind of awful thing from the point of view of the beaver that is discovered in the 18th century is that if you take castoreum and you wipe it over a cage, beavers will go
怀孕了想吃冰淇淋，对，你想吃冰淇淋，然后你要出去吃晚闻，你想身上香喷喷的，对，完全正确。所以海狸嘛，你知道的，营养价值很高，对吧？它们的皮毛可以让你做一顶三角帽。对。它们还有这种分泌物。这种神奇的东西。它是家具和冰淇淋风味的基底。所以在方方面面，你可以理解为什么人们追逐它们。但从海狸的角度来看，在18世纪发现的一件可怕的事情是，如果你拿海狸香抹在笼子上，海狸就会
straight for it. They kind of go, brilliant, let's go for that. And they plunge in and the cage closes or grabs their leg or whatever, and they can be got. And so this massively, massively intensifies the ease of trapping beaver. And what then happens in the 1820s is that you have a teenager in New York who develops a kind of very lightweight trap. And he's a guy called Sewell Newhouse. And these traps are called Newhouse traps. And they are sold in huge, huge numbers to the Hudson's Bay Company. So they've got the bait and now they've got the lightweight traps. They can just take them out. It doesn't matter how remote the creeks may be you can now go out with your castoreum with your your new house trap and that basically there is nowhere that is so remote
径直朝它走去。它们会想，太棒了，我们就冲这个去吧。然后它们扑进去，笼子关上或者抓住它们的腿什么的，它们就被抓住了。因此，这极大、极大地增强了捕捉海狸的便利性。随后在18世纪20年代，纽约出现了一个少年，他开发了一种非常轻便的陷阱。他叫索厄尔·纽豪斯。这些陷阱被称为纽豪斯陷阱。它们以极大的数量卖给了哈德逊湾公司。所以他们有了诱饵，现在又有了轻便的陷阱。他们可以直接把它们带出去。不管小溪有多偏远，你现在都可以带着你的海狸香、带着你的纽豪斯陷阱出发，基本上没有哪个地方是如此偏远
that uh you can't trap a beaver gosh this is a very this is taking a very sad turn tom well but but you know this is one we've talked about before on the podcast. We've talked about what happened to the buffalo on the plains of the United States. We've talked about the passenger pigeon in our episode on the pigeons. They went extinct. This process of industrial level slaughter is a feature of the Europeanization of both the United States and, I'm sad to say, Canada. But in Canada, there is a consciousness that, in a way, it's because beavers are so, they provide so much that they are a resource that needs conserving.
以至于……呃，你捕不到海狸。天哪，这是一个非常，这发生了一个非常悲伤的转变，汤姆。嗯，但是，但是你知道，这是我们在播客中讨论过的一个话题。我们讨论过美国平原上的野牛发生了什么。我们在关于鸽子的那一集里讨论过旅鸽。它们灭绝了。这种工业化水平的屠杀是美国和，我很遗憾地说，加拿大的欧洲化过程的一个特征。但在加拿大，有一种意识，某种程度上是因为海狸如此，它们提供了如此多的东西，以至于它们是一种需要保护的资源。
And there are government officials. So the Cree guy who said we're going to lose our income. It's not just the native peoples who realize this. There are colonial administrators who appreciate it as well. And they try to start to introduce conservation measures, much to the hostility of the trappers. There is no tradition of conserving animals at this point, but it's a kind of groundbreaking program where over the course of the 19th century and into the 20th century, there are attempts, but they're feeble because it doesn't have mass support. There isn't a kind of sense among most
而且有政府官员。所以那个说我们会失去收入的克里族人。不仅原住民意识到了这一点。有些殖民地管理者也意识到了。他们试图开始引入保护措施，尽管遭到了捕猎者的强烈反对。当时没有保护动物的传统，但这是一个开创性的项目，在19世纪到20世纪期间，有过一些尝试，但它们很微弱，因为没有得到大众的支持。大多数人并没有一种……
people living in Canada and the broader world that they have an emotional investment in conserving these extraordinary creatures. And what happens in the 20th century is that the beaver gets a very, very charismatic spokesman who becomes a global figure, a global spokesman for the process of conservation. And he is a man called Grey Owl. And he speaks with the authority of this tradition among the native peoples of Canada that you have to, you can, of course, trap animals and use them, but you have to show them respect. And that kind of wiping them out on a vast industrial scale is not the done thing. And it helps when Grail gives this message to white Canadians, it helps that he looks, I mean, he looks brilliantly wise. So he's the absolute kind of embodiment of how people would imagine a kind of a very wise in the words, in the phrase of the
生活在加拿大及更广泛世界的人们对保护这些非凡的生物有一种情感上的投资。而在20世纪发生的事情是，海狸迎来了一位非常、非常有魅力的发言人，他成为一个全球人物，一个全球保护进程的代言人。他是一个叫“灰猫头鹰”的人。他带着加拿大原住民传统权威的声音说话，即你必须，当然你可以捕捉动物并利用它们，但你必须表现出对它们的尊重。以巨大的工业规模消灭它们并不是一件体面的事。当灰猫头鹰将这个信息传达给白人加拿大人时，这很有帮助，他的外表，我的意思是，他看起来聪明绝顶。所以他是人们想象中的那种非常聪明的绝对化身，用那个时代的话来说，
time, a red Indian. This is not the kind of red Indian who will't this is not a the kind of red indian who will scalp you this is the kind of red indian who will speak with the wisdom of many many thousands of years of living with oh gosh he does look very wise i've i've just googled him he does so he had so he has black hair he has an aquiline nose he has and he he dresses like a kind of stereotype of a native american so here actually like an apache he claims to be the um that his mother is an apache he has a buckskin vest uh he wears moccasins um and he has the uh the woodsman skills of the uh the ojibwe people of northern ontario among which he he lives so looking at a photo of him, Tom, he looks to me like a man who absolutely is the embodiment of a kind of Native American, what do they call them in Canada, First Nations, kind of
一个“红皮肤印第安人”。这不是那种会……这不是那种会剥你头皮的红皮肤印第安人，这是那种带着数千年与自然共存的智慧说话的红皮肤印第安人。噢天哪，他看起来确实很聪明，我刚刚谷歌了一下他，确实如此。所以他有一头黑发，他有一个鹰钩鼻，他穿着一种北美原住民的刻板印象的衣服，实际上就像一个阿帕奇人。他声称自己的母亲是阿帕奇人，他穿着鹿皮背心，穿着莫卡辛鞋，并且他拥有生活在安大略省北部的奥吉布瓦人的森林人技能。所以看着他的照片，汤姆，在我看来，他是一个绝对体现了北美原住民（他们在加拿大叫什么？第一民族）的那种……
authenticity and dignity and spirituality and all these. And what gives a kind of real heft to his message is that he himself had originally been a beaver trapper. Right. his message is that he himself had originally been a beaver trapper. And he had then kind of had a Damascene conversion and he'd become this great enthusiast, this great for conserving the beaver. He becomes the protector of the beaver, the father of the beaver,
真实性、尊严、灵性以及所有这些的人。赋予他的信息真正分量的是，他本人最初也是一个海狸捕猎者。没错。他的信息是他本人最初也是一个海狸捕猎者。然后他经历了一种类似大马士革式的皈依，成为了一个狂热的支持者，一个保护海狸的狂热分子。他成了海狸的保护者，海狸之父，
if you like. And he starts writing articles about it. He starts writing books about it. And then in 1930, the head of this kind of what this, this, this national park, so Riding Mountain National Park in Manitoba,
如果你愿意这么叫的话。他开始撰写关于它的文章。他开始撰写关于它的书。然后在1930年，这个国家公园（曼itoba的Riding Mountain国家公园）的负责人
sends in a film crew to film him hanging out with his beaver friends. And they make a nine-minute film. And this is the first professional film ever made of beavers in the wild. And so people in New York or London can see what beavers in the wild actually look like and how they behave. And they have this guy who looks the embodiment of First Nations. Absolutely embodiment of the dignity, the wisdom, all that kind of stuff. And as a result of that, he gets an official role in riding Mounted National Park.
派出了一个摄制组去拍摄他和他的海狸朋友们在一起的场景。他们制作了一部九分钟的短片。这是有史以来第一部关于野外海狸的专业电影。因此，纽约或伦敦的人们可以看到野外海狸究竟是什么样子以及它们的行为方式。他们有这个看起来像第一民族化身的人。绝对是尊严、智慧等等一切的化身。因此，他在骑马山国家公园获得了一个官方职位。
He's basically beaver guardian. It's his job to look after them and to boost their population and this wins him kind of international fame and so he goes on a tour of britain he goes on a tour of the united states and his message is always the same we have to conserve the beaver and in 1938 he dies of pneumonia and his his legacy, particularly in Canada, is this sense that it's not just about economic self-interest. There is a kind of moral duty to conserve this extraordinary creature. And he's at the head of what over the course of the 20th century will become a kind of mountain campaign to conserve wildlife populations that are under huge threat. What an amazing story, Tom. What an amazing guy i mean i mean it's extraordinary that he's not better known in britain well and all the more amazing
他基本上是海狸守护者。他的工作是照顾它们并促进它们的数量增长，这为他赢得了国际声誉，于是他去英国巡回演出，去美国巡回演出，他的信息始终如一：我们必须保护海狸。1938年，他死于肺炎，他的遗产，特别是在加拿大，是这样一种意识：这不仅仅关乎经济自利。保护这种非凡的生物有一种道德责任。他处于20世纪将成为一场旨在保护面临巨大威胁的野生动物种群的宏伟运动的最前沿。多么了不起的故事，汤姆。多么了不起的人，我的意思是，我的意思是，他在英国居然不太知名，这太不可思议了。嗯，更不可思议的是
because in fact he is from britain oh no oh he's he's he's actually um he's not a native american oh no he's from hastings and his real name was was archibald stansfeld bellini archibald bellini archibald bellini oh my word what a twist at school he was a huge fan of cowboy and indian stories and he became obsessed by them so he's basically role-playing as a Native American. Well, so that's what his critics say. But I think people who are kinder to him would say that he goes out to Canada. He has an unbelievably complicated love life that involves him falling in love with and then dumping a succession of Native American women. Okay. Well, that doesn't necessarily paint him in a good light, Tom. No, but I think, I mean, he adored the culture.
事实上他来自英国。哦，不。哦，他其实……呃，他不是北美原住民。哦，不，他来自黑斯廷斯，他的真名叫阿奇博尔德·斯坦斯菲尔德·贝利尼。阿奇博尔德·贝利尼。阿奇博尔德·贝利尼。我的天哪，多么戏剧性的转折！在学校里，他是牛仔和印第安人故事的超级粉丝，并对它们着迷。所以他基本上是在扮演一个北美原住民。好吧，他的批评者是这么说的。但我认为对他更宽容的人会说他去了加拿大。他有着令人难以置信复杂的感情生活，包括爱上一位又一位原住民女性然后又抛弃她们。好吧，这不一定能把他描绘成一个好人，汤姆。不，但我想，我的意思是，他崇拜这种文化。
And he does become absolutely passionate about the need to conserve the beavers. But he's also becomes, you know, he identifies so strongly with Native American culture as opposed to, you know, white Canadian culture that he just wants to become a part of them. And, you know, and he does, you know and he does you know he does great work and the legacy one of the measures of his legacy not just his legacy but i mean he's he's the most famous spokesman for beaver conservation is that today in north america there are about 10 to 15 million beaver so that's you know that's a huge huge recovery because at one point they were down to about half a million, maybe even lower. So they could easily have gone extinct.
而且他确实对保护海狸的需求充满了热情。但他也变得，你知道的，他如此强烈地认同北美原住民文化，而不是（你知道的）白人加拿大文化，以至于他只想成为他们的一部分。而且，你知道，他也做了，你知道，他也做了，你知道，他做了出色的工作，他遗产的衡量标准之一，不仅是他的遗产，我的意思是他是海狸保护最著名的代言人，那就是今天在北美大约有1000到1500万只海狸，所以你知道，这是一个巨大、巨大的恢复，因为曾经一度它们的数量下降到大约五十万，甚至可能更低。所以它们很容易就会灭绝。
And are they still being trapped? Yes, but under very tight control. I mean, it's very, very carefully regulated and they are recovering. I mean, so much so that actually in 2007, a beaver was, a wild beaver was seen in the bronx um so you know that first time and i think about over two centuries that a wild beaver had been seen in you know the new york area um and and the other good news story so you asked about about europe let's let's focus on britain yeah i know this is about canada but but it's this is this is quite touching dominic because it actually relates to you and me so So beavers were in Britain.
它们还在被捕猎吗？是的，但在非常严格的控制下。我的意思是，这是非常、非常严格监管的，它们正在恢复。我的意思是，甚至在2007年，一只海狸，一只野生海狸在布朗克斯被看到，所以你知道，那是两个多世纪以来第一次在纽约地区看到野生海狸，另一个好消息是，你问到了欧洲，让我们把焦点放在英国。是的，我知道这是关于加拿大的，但这很感人，多米尼克，因为它实际上与你我有关。所以英国曾经有海狸。
We already talked about how Anglo-Saxon women loved to wear necklaces made from their incisors. But they had basically gone extinct in England and Wales probably by the 14th century. So was the Normansans isn't it although bizarrely i read in uh the missing links um by ross barnett which is a fabulous book about um mammals in britain that have gone extinct uh and he says that in 1789 apparently a bounty was paid on a beaver in bolton percy in yorkshire but that's so aberrant that people think it maybe it was an otter or something nobody's quite sure but anyway so probably beaver was snipped by the 14th century in England Wales by 16th century in Scotland and since then they haven't existed however you may remember
我们已经讨论过盎格鲁-撒克逊女性多么喜欢戴用它们的门牙制作的项链。但它们在英格兰和威尔士可能在14世纪就已经灭绝了。所以是诺曼人时期，对吧？尽管奇怪的是，我在罗斯·巴内特（Ross Barnett）所著的《缺失的环节》（The Missing Links）中读到，这是一本关于英国已灭绝哺乳动物的极棒的书，他说在1789年，约克郡博尔顿珀西（Bolton Percy）似乎还为一只海狸支付了赏金，但这太反常了，人们认为那可能是一只水獭或其他什么，没有人十分确定。但无论如何，所以英国和威尔士的海狸大概在14世纪就消失了，苏格兰则在16世纪，自那以后它们就不存在了。然而，你可能还记得
that when Dominion came out you very kindly interviewed me as part of the um Budley Salterton Literary Festival Tom I remember it well i remember it very well you were gutted because i interviewed you in budley salterton on the day that the times compared me with thucydides yeah and you were absolutely you're put you're in a foul mood yeah it's very downcast but i then cheered up because I suddenly realised that Budley Salterton is on the River Otter, which confusingly is the site of the release of beavers into the wild. So the beavers of the River Otter. Oh, right. And that they were then further beavers released into the Forest of Dean.
当《多米尼恩》（Dominion）出版时，你非常客气地邀请我参加巴德利萨尔顿文学节，汤姆。我记得很清楚，我记得非常清楚。你当时很不高兴，因为我在巴德利萨尔顿采访了你，而就在那天，《泰晤士报》把你拿来和修昔底德作比较。是的，你当时绝对是，你心情糟糕透了。是的，非常沮丧。但后来我又高兴起来了，因为我突然意识到巴德利萨尔顿在水獭河（River Otter）畔，令人困惑的是，那里正是将海狸放归野外的地点。所以水獭河的海狸。哦，对了。随后还有更多海狸被放归到迪恩森林（Forest of Dean）。
There had already been beavers released into the into north of Scotland. And these are Canadian beavers being released, are they? No, this is the Eurasian beaver. So this is the kind of beaver that originally lived in Britain. I know lots of people may not be keen on the current government, but one thing that is a splendid achievement that the government did, and I particularly praise Michael Gove, there was a wonderful picture of him gazing lovingly at these beavers
苏格兰北部已经有海狸被放归了。这些是放归的加拿大海狸吗？不，这是欧亚海狸。所以这是原本生活在英国的那种海狸。我知道很多人可能不喜欢现政府，但政府取得的一项辉煌成就，我特别称赞迈克尔·戈夫（Michael Gove），有一张他深情注视着这些海狸的照片
being released into the wild. Yes. One of the great achievements of Michael Gove's political career, he, as agriculture secretary, was responsible for reintroducing beaver into the wild. In Ross Barnett's book, you know, he says he's got all these kinds of other animals that have gone extinct. So, you know, woolly mamm mammoths cave lions uh aurochs bears lynx all these other creatures uh but the beaver is the only one that's been restored that's that's come back right and so you know britain is following in the wake of canada and i i like to think that grey owl would be very pleased to know that it's not only in canada but in his native
被放归野外。是的。迈克尔·戈夫政治生涯中的伟大成就之一，他作为农业大臣，负责将海狸重新引入野外。在罗斯·巴内特的书中，你知道，他说他拥有所有这些其他已经灭绝的动物，所以，你知道，猛犸象、洞狮、原牛、熊、山猫所有这些其他生物，但海狸是唯一被恢复的、回来的生物，对吧？所以，你知道，英国正在步加拿大的后尘，我喜欢认为灰猫头鹰会很高兴得知，不仅在加拿大，而且在他的祖国
his native england what was his real name again? Adrian or something. No, Archibald. Archibald Bellini. So Michael Gove, friend of, friend of Beaver. I mean, that's a, that's something to have on your tombstone, isn't it? Yes. Yes. It's a, it's wonderful. So there it is. Canada, of course, Canada, of course, the home of Leslie Nielsen. Yeah. And I think it's wonderful that we've done an episode on the beaver as Canada's contribution to this ongoing series of episodes that we're doing.
他的祖国英格兰……他真叫什么名字来着？阿德里安还是什么的。不，阿奇博尔德。阿奇博尔德·贝利尼。所以迈克尔·戈夫，海狸的朋友。我的意思是，那是可以刻在你的墓碑上的东西，对吧？是的。是的。这太棒了。所以就这样。加拿大，当然，加拿大，莱斯利·尼尔森的故乡。是的。我认为我们做了一集关于海狸的节目，作为加拿大对我们正在进行的这一系列节目的贡献，这真是太棒了。
It's a wonderful story. And I think you've done it justice. I think we can safely say that was a tour de force. A tour de force and a tour de beaver. You're too kind. And thank you very much. I hope our Canadian listeners will consider that we've done justice to the richness and sophistication of their history
这是一个精彩的故事。我认为你把它讲得很精彩。我想我们可以安全地说这是一次杰作。一次杰作，一次海狸之旅。你太客气了。非常感谢。我希望我们的加拿大听众会认为我们公正对待了他们历史的丰富性和复杂性，
and we'll be back next time for more World Cup related shenanigans goodbye bye-bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次会回来讨论更多与世界杯相关的恶作剧，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishtertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。